de vuelta al colegio miles de
estudiantes de primaria de madrid
regresaron a las aulas para encontrarse
con clases que nunca imaginaron recibir
como lavarse las manos y usar
mascarillas protectoras por ejemplo y
verse limitados a interactuar con otros
niños
los compañeros de él
uno por uno los estudiantes entraron de
manera escalonada para evitar
aglomeraciones en la puerta toma de
temperatura y distanciamiento social el
inicio del nuevo año escolar genera
alivio para algunos padres de familia no
estoy contenta porque vuelve a sus
actividades para nosotros es una ilusión
porque al fin de cuentas tanto a
confinamiento y ya ves la alegría de los
enanos encontrarse es maravilloso pero
el regreso a clases causa temores sobre
un aumento en el número de contagios por
kobe 19 especialmente por el rebrote de
los últimos días que llevó a españa a
convertirse en el primer país de europa
occidental en sobrepasar el medio millón
de casos positivos pues que yo soy
profesora y todavía no he traído a mis
hijos al colegio porque no hay seguridad
aunque han pasado seis meses desde que
el país ordenó el cierre de escuelas el
gobierno reconoció que el riesgo existe
y que es probable que haya un impacto
que pueda empezar a verse en unas dos
semanas